hey everyone this is Steve landrope with
collider and I am thrilled to be in the
collider Sundance Studio sponsored by
Saratoga spring water thank you Saratoga
I see you right there yeah it costs a
whole bunch of money to be at Sundance
plastic yeah exactly lovely yeah it's
very good
um and I've actually been we were off on
a tangent so I really want to
congratulate you guys
um on sometimes I think about dying I've
been butchering it all day sometimes I
think about dying um so jumping in I
want to say sincere congratulations for
being part of Sundance
um I love this festival and I'm curious
I want to start right actually from the
beginning most people aren't who are
watching this will not have seen the
movie yet and they might not have seen
the short film that it's based on so how
have you been describing it to like
friends and family well I I've been
describing it as a woman named Fran who
lives in a small Seaside town and she
lives a very simple life
but she's pretty convinced that everyone
else around her is really good at being
a person and she's not she feels really
hard to connect with others even though
I think deep down she really wants to
um I think that she is
Unsure how to live life in a meaningful
way
I think that she is searching for some
way to make sense of that feeling of
being lost and lonely
and so that's really what or she's at
but the story that we follow is one of
her
um
learning how to find joy in the very
small idiosyncrasies of life that that's
actually the secret it's not some big
amazing event that descends on you and
helps you transcend life it's actually
focusing on the details of like what you
had for breakfast enjoying that and
looking at someone's eyes and having
conversation and sharing tea and but
that's actually the secret it's really
simple but she gets there in a way
that's really
funny it's actually quite comic and
heartwarming and sometimes heartbreaking
and fun conversations on slack oh yeah
yeah but but seriously like that's how
we occupy our time right it's not I
don't I've never jumped out of a plane I
don't know it's like to like save
Humanity but I do know what it's like to
share a joke with a friend over text and
not really making your day
um I know what it is to surprise someone
with a muffin for breakfast and that
like sparking a conversation and it
soothing maybe and otherwise really
tedious day and like those are the
dramas of my life and I don't think that
makes them small dramas are
insignificant I actually think they're
really significant exactly
you know I mean that's the thing I like
about Sundance though and interviews
like this is that we're not in like the
Four Seasons in a hotel it's it's very
much like we're here just to celebrate
movies and like warts and all you know
however we do this but for all four of
you uh I'm curious what was it about the
script and story that said oh I
absolutely want to do this I have to do
this
Daisy I'm actually also going to steal a
bit of Brit's answer from yesterday too
um I mean initially I just think the
script was beautiful I thought the
character was wonderful but also the
setting was beautiful I always got to
the end and however many times I read it
before we got there I always cried at
the end because I was like it's the I
think um do you wish you could unknow me
is the saddest thing I think I've ever
read but also
um the tiny victory of someone
establishing some sort of connection
which is the most difficult thing for
them was always beautiful and to
Brittany's Point sorry
it was also just the thought of being
part of a group of people and honestly
it exceeded expectations we actually
loved each other loved each other so
much and we had such a great time on set
but it was really wonderful to be part
of a group of people who were so
distinct and unique and
um and Rachel really let everybody like
live their most best beautiful lives on
film
I'm just gonna take Daisy's answer and
say it was beautiful
that's great
neck with friends uh character like I've
gone through some of that stuff and
still go through some of that stuff so I
wanted to be a part of it got really sad
no by the end of it sure but now do you
feel happy looking into your eyes I do
bless you I love you too Brittany can I
go next do you mind yes please work but
um I don't know like there are a lot of
I always forget about this with this
project is my character's name is
Garrett and when you're parvage you
don't get to play a lot of Garrett's
often you don't get to play a character
where it's just the character first or
we don't have to deal with what's his
orientation what's his race and then
knowing that like Dave was in as like
the male lead romantic lead in a sense
I'm like wait you know like we we don't
get to do that that often I mean I don't
look like no don't don't do that don't
do that we're on up we're on up we're
gonna take it you do belong we do belong
and we are part of this world so it was
just show and I've told I've spoken with
Rachel about this it was so casually
diverse we have people with disabilities
we have every color every race under the
rainbow on it but that's not the
priority you know it's still the story
of Fran and connecting and loneliness
but for me that is a big draw that is a
big draw when I I don't want to like
swing that pendulum like I am not shy of
my indian-ness or my gayness but even my
own partner I was like was your
character gay I'm like up to you to
decide and so that was just a gift for
some of us actors you know we have to
view it with that lens before we even
read the script and then seen Rachel's
other film was my big reason why I
wanted to do it
Brittany my love hi um I I really uh the
script actually uh
it scared me a little bit when I read it
just because it was so vulnerable and I
think feelings uh that Fran and many of
us feel is a really terrifying thing
because we always keep it in the shadows
and uh
and just being able to be a part of of
kind of creating the environment uh and
helping
helping make that uh atmosphere uh come
to life and with the contrast of the
outside world and Fran's internal
monologue which we see on Daisy's face
but it's not no it was in public and
private a lot didn't we yes we did I
remember that so that was a reason why I
wanted to be a part of this and it was a
wonderful experience
one of the things first I just want to
address what you said which I totally
agree with yeah I think that it was it's
uh it's great when films have that
diversity but it's not being it's not
it's that's not the point but it's just
it's part of it it's that it's real and
that's one of the things that I really
loved about the film it's just real
people you know and yeah so one of the
things that I'm writing it exactly one
of the things obviously the office
setting is everything if that doesn't
work this movie does not work yes so
talk a little bit about filming the
office settings was it all done at once
and how did you want to shoot it and you
know and play it to make it feel like
you know this has been happening for you
know years and years yeah that was a
huge concern uh not in terms of negative
concern but just uh something that
occupied my thoughts I'm sure their
thoughts uh all of my department heads
thoughts when we were prepping because
that was so much of the lifeblood of the
story as you said
um well it definitely started with
design and thinking about what is this
play place and the script was written
with so much invitation for my own
creativity to take hold
um then the writers all being from the
theater they were incredibly specific in
the psychologies of the actors the
motivations all the food you need to
make good decisions but there was so
much space to invent and I got to sort
of decide okay where is this office what
is it what do they do where are they at
and when I went to Oregon I just saw
this Fishing World this port world and
the seaside world and I wanted to engage
with the environment there uh the
industry's there and really showcase a
sense of play so that was the first
thing and then from there we created an
environment that had to look lived in I
wanted it to look like this was a place
that maybe got renovated in 1992 and
still hadn't yet seen new anything
and I want to make sure that the actors
all had their desks were designed with
some character in mind where they could
interact with their computers they had
assets they could play with you had us
bring talismans yep you had to bring
five pieces right and but you couldn't
show me until we were there and some
and some Secrets Sean's were regrets and
I brought nothing
well I was like my character I had to
fly a long way so I was like can I fit
five things in my bag but also I was
like Fran wouldn't have things on her
desk no but that's the right choice
that's I mean just like positive space
and negative space you know either is an
additive and I think uh that was the
right choice and then that still worked
and it worked very well
um so that contributed to it and then in
terms of shooting it
um obviously we had these scripted
pieces and I know Dustin and I uh wanted
every angle to be fresh we never reused
a setup
um for any given scene
um that kind of variety allowed us to
maximize the photographic and and
emotional potential of this space that
we didn't want to feel too tired in
terms of how we're engaging with the
image because we also knew that it was
designed to be kind of
um tired in terms of its Aesthetics
um so there was that idea and then with
the aliveness and even what you're
saying about Humanity being so important
to characterizations it was very
important to the storytelling so I let
them play you absolutely do she Rachel
is one of the most gentle directors I've
worked with where there would be times
when we would it was Theater Camp so we
were also just like hanging out and just
like and it's in character all day yes
and then we'd be talking and then all of
a sudden you'd see Rachel like like
Britney go and I'd be like oh we're
filming
see uh Dustin the camera team kind of
like spider over chocolate corner like
turn the camera on I'm like oh we're
just let's just keep going you know like
and it was that was so much I was
encouraged that they would live in their
spaces that the idle time would be used
as play time even in scripted scenes
like the conference room scene where we
you know let people's instincts run and
they're so great a company I mean it was
like we were a rep company they would do
it we'd do like a couple runs and we'd
be improving but they we would know what
was working or that they would know that
as a company what was working and they
would remember those beats so even when
we went back to the edit we had cut
points everywhere because they go oh
that beat's working and they would still
make sure that we could get that set
like a good Theater Company yeah and no
improviser likes when you repeat stuff I
mean or when you
I love that the writers gave such
Freedom with the script and so much room
for play but you have the parameters The
Improv within scripted works you have to
go by that you can't say like oh I have
10 kids like uh act one said you have
none you know that's right and I always
remember like that there are moments
that you do remember that like just stay
within these comments I had a playable
reality in given circums news and then
that that sets your limits which then
actually opens the door to opportunity
and choice as an actor I think I'm
curious for the actors when you by the
way how long did you have to actually
make the movie is do you have a like a
was it a 20-something day is it the 40 I
mean let me I'll actually think about it
no have a guess have a guess hold on
I mean I'm gonna
uh 25 to 35 18. was it 18 21 was it 21
but I will also say we wrapped early
many days and I'm talking like hours
early
yes Rachel was very deliberate and very
intentional and knew what we needed to
get and we got it and that was that I
was blessed with a company too I also
like how I gave myself a 10-day window
here's the thing though he's like it's
very hard when you're not a Marvel movie
or a mega budget movie financing is
really really hard nowadays and so you
know you don't have a lot of time it's
you have to do everything in a very
tight schedule so for the actors I was
just going to say everyone had to
hunk down and there were a lot of
um you know Financial sacrifices made
for individuals particularly the
producers in coming in and making it
work and people were doing like five
different jobs and like one of our
producers was our first ad like everyone
was doing that so it really not just
costs wise crew-wise it really felt like
a company too so obviously when you're
making a film with a tight schedule and
you got to hit your marks and days for
all four of the actors I'm curious what
day did you have on the schedule uh
where that you had circled where you're
like oh this is going to be a really
tough day or was it every day
um
not in I didn't I was gonna say every
day no
[Laughter]
yeah
she was nervous I was nervous probably a
week and a half meeting everyone really
I not you well I was uh completely
nervous the whole time but the highest
in a week and a half but I think The
Boathouse was a long or yeah we knew
that was going to be tough but also we
were given a lot of room it wasn't like
we have to fulfill all of these things
and there's no room to like play in that
and no room to sort of get it wrong and
try things and yeah so not I mean my
thing was just the the house after the
car because I was like to be alone and
have to do all of that and it's not that
I don't know that it's it's the lowest
point I would say for Fran so I was very
aware of like whoa
um but also by that point we knew how
amazing all the crew were and treating
the
set so carefully and so respectfully
um so also there was a lot of comfort in
that when you know that everyone is just
together on the journey
yeah I I agree I I I was I don't really
remember how long I I was there for
maybe like a week and a half right the
first because I only stayed a few days
after you yeah because yeah because you
had the extra yeah it was a week it was
a full week of shooting yeah yeah for
for the office uh it was it was I would
say I know I wasn't there for the whole
shoot but just the experience of of it's
so impressive to me that you guys
had so many corners that had to be cut
but it was it was the most pleasant
experience on a job I've ever had we all
it was it was and
to wrap hours early and and be so
intentional but then to have the freedom
that we had yeah I mean normally I
wasn't like I lost me I mean it was just
you guys were so good we still had room
to play I got to play even beyond what
you guys were doing and then it was like
you know
go home rest be prepared that's more
important than me I don't know indulging
myself un needlessly the meet and greet
our first cast and crew dinner when we
all got to story of it oh that was scary
I didn't know who was who yeah and then
I'm like I literally I did like Dave I
went to Dave first is that a rogue some
place
on the water I don't know ethnic yeah
that's true yes it's true to my brown
brother first I was like I know you but
that was the scariest thing Brittany
walks in I'm like oh and then Daisy you
still have that moment of like the first
time you meet Daisy is still like oh
that's Daisy and then by the end you're
like days
but like that is the most nerve-wracking
because you just you don't know what
it's going to be but after that dinner
then shooting I hope at least for those
of us in the office was cake in this
sense because we knew we were going to
be taken care of but literally walking
into the restaurant was like oh my God
please like me first day of school yeah
is that Vibe I drove to the wrong I
drove through that you know that bridge
yeah so I first got there I went on that
bridge and it was a big one over the
water yeah I was like I'm leaving
Astoria and I was like where am I going
Canada I was going back again
Oregon Washington you're back home I'm
never letting you drive me I got better
bro I got better I did I had a whole
three weeks of practice in a rental car
Daisy would drive us around there would
be a lot of times like we'd wrap early
all right let's go to Jordan go to the
restaurant let's go to the bar and I'd
be like Daisy can you drop us off
or that remember that haunted you sent
an article when we filmed in that town
you sent an article the next day that
the town and that theater was haunted it
was the most haunted place in Oregon
yeah really yeah the movie's there yeah
yeah it's a nice haunted town in Oregon
it looks pretty haunted in the film I
was like
that's scary it was old even the deer
the deer said it was haunted
we went to the doctor's house David I
did yeah yeah we went out because we're
in Astoria Oregon so Kindergarten Cop
Free Willy it's the film Museum which
was the old jail really I didn't make it
there was it I literally I went around
it in 20 seconds but it was great you
know a lot of a lot of photos are Free
Willy they're very proud of it isn't
Astoria The Goonies yeah Goonies Goonies
Kindergarten Cop Free Willy and
sometimes I think about dying yeah yeah
uh Goonies is actually one of my
favorite films I know I mean that movie
anyway that's a completely separate
thing so jump jump uh I like talking
about editing because it's where the
film obviously comes together so how did
the film change in the editing room in
ways that perhaps you weren't expecting
um there's definitely
proposed
in the edit
you were anticipating that it might but
we were opening ourselves up to
Discovery based on the bits that we
found because it as we mentioned there
was a lot of play
um and we wanted to fill out that
environment and that world with all of
these idios increased idiosyncrasies
relationships beats so we anticipated a
lot of the office to be in a lot of
invention in terms of how do we build
that into the spine of the written story
so there was that aspect of it and then
there's a section you mentioned with
slack screens
um and that that we definitely had that
conversation
um in the script but
Ryan and I really wanted to find
something that continued to create the
sense of 360 life
um to have their conversation be rooted
in an ongoing reality that is sort of
ricocheting off of it emotionally we
thought it would create a unique kind of
energy it would also
um heighten the sense of how she's
behaving with around others we wouldn't
lose touch with that how our outsize can
be interacting with our insides uh and
so we wanted to have this other
energetic conversation somewhat
hilarious conversation going on around
them and so it kind of came on it came
out as this like altmanesque moment of
like 360 life conversations going on
around the slack screen it kind of
heightened almost like to a a Keaton s
Mania to it or something so that was
really fun to discover that
um and then the opening was an entire
Discovery as well we knew we wanted to
have
um about a handful of really intentional
photographs that could live as their own
pieces of still art if need be
um and they had to follow certain and
rules when we shot them they had to be
something that Fran would notice or see
if she was walking to or from work in
the morning or the evening so it also be
at certain times of the day that would
believe be on her walk and it had to
connect with the things that she's
feeling loneliness uh the the beauty of
the Unseen strange thing
um nature and places it shouldn't be
that merging of the fantasy in reality
so we had those things but what is that
Arrangement what is the uh associate of
grammar telling the audience Not only
was each image saying but what is that
progression and marrying that with a
piece of music that had to be designed
as well by Dabney it was a huge
collaboration that opening me and
dabbing and Ryan so that was I don't
know how that answered your question the
interesting thing about doing a Sundance
interview is that I have so many
specific questions but because no one
has seen the movie I don't want to spoil
anything sure so this is a very like I
don't want to say it's a superficial
cover like but it's you can't go deep I
can't ask you about any party scene and
bathtub sequence or you know I'm trying
to avoid but still say words that people
might have so that sounds totally
different than what it is I will
actually say on the editing front in a
general way which I found very
interesting is um
the more emotional if one should call it
that which one shouldn't because
everything is an emotion the more
um
uh demonstrative emotional scenes for
Fran you
've trimmed a little and I found it
interesting because I was like oh oh
okay cool so it felt a little less
sentimental from what we filmed to what
I saw but it was quite profound because
then when my mom saw the film she was so
overwhelmed with emotion that I was like
huh what do you know and it was a really
so you're meaning like um some of the
scenes we were talking with with yeah so
there's well there's a scene where there
was a sort of leading up to it that
wasn't in there so it just is just the
shot of me on the sofa and then
um the end of the film
um where me and Dave had a scene
together you used uh takes which were a
little more contained and it was just a
very interesting exercise because I was
like okay cool
um and it still was so
tangible that it was really interesting
because Rachel's spoken about the fact
that it's not sort of using and it's not
um the film isn't there's like No Agenda
to what this is it's just a story about
some people and connecting and
um because there's no judgment on it I
don't like I'm not explaining it right
but it was a very interesting editing
choice I found because watching I was
like oh okay cool there was just more
when we were working on it it there was
just more uh in in what was being fought
against as opposed to being always
released and so when there was release
it felt like you could feel the work it
took for her to release it all
um but it was also there was a couple
things one I remember we were getting
towards the end of the shooting year on
instincts as an actor you were coming to
me and saying I think I think that this
line I think I can just clip that and
you were feeling that she doesn't want
that you were already psychologically
and emotionally pushing the character in
that direction not only in your work but
in how you were coming to me about those
scenes towards the end and so I think it
came from those instincts on your part
and it not only came from the
performance but it certainly informed me
going forward
so I can't imagine what it's like as an
actor where you have made a movie and
you're not exactly sure because you've
given so much so many different versions
of a performance or you don't really
know what the movie is going to be until
you watch it and then I can't imagine
what that is like happily surprise
you're always I think for most of us we
hadn't seen it I you know like and I was
surprised how funny it was and the edit
and that's why like coming from TV you
know multicam even like you make a
single time you make friends with the
editor because it's the editor who's
going to make me look like either a
Cloyne [__] or a comedic genius and
it is because we just said we just say
jokes but it's that timing it's that bit
will they laugh you build in that kind
almost that room for a laughter in a
theater like it's that's what I thought
about all the time like the edit it was
funny yeah I mean again we're getting
the timing yeah I mean what you said
Thank you Dave thank you listen um I
have to wrap with you guys but before I
rap I know they're going to kill me um
Daisy I think you're starting to film a
movie on Monday if I'm not mistaken uh
which is why I am believing Sundance so
what would you like to tell about this
project because I know it's very
personal to you I will also say another
shout out to the producers of sometimes
I think about dying who are very helpful
um because we were early stages then and
they really gave me Alex was very
generous in giving me a produced credit
but they were very open with how it was
made and uh in terms of the financials
of making a movie which I hadn't done
before
um so thank you
um the movie uh follows a family a woman
who is at home
with a baby
um pushed slightly Beyond her limits and
her husband who is chaperoning their
daughter into a film set
um and who falls in love with the
actress playing the mother and it's uh
fancy versus reality and what things
mean and different perspectives and what
they lend to um how we view characters
and also what the audience's biases May
inform when they're projecting onto the
characters so it's a lot of things but
my husband Tom wrote it
um it's excellent and we have an amazing
uh cast and crew and honestly from
working on this like
it's just like the power of what people
can do together if everyone is like this
is what we're doing we're holding hands
we're like
you know we have limited time we have
limited budget this is what we have to
do and we get to be part of amazing
things are you the mom are you the I'm
the Mom hey it's called Magpie yeah I
was just going to ask you what just to
confirm the title
um okay listen I have to stop with you
guys I'm just going to say seriously
congrats on being part of Sundance I
wish you guys nothing but the best and
enjoy the afternoon